additional relationships are they dead
are they still alive when we say
traditional
let I want to find out because people
have their different views of what the
traditional relationship is
um
can I ask what people's views of a
traditional relationship is to them
jump in anybody jump in the woman the
nurturer and the man the protector and
provider
are those dead yeah
undeniably so I say really yeah I think
um
I think it's difficult for men to want
to provide because of
city girls
um and things are like
um and that's understandable and I think
women are we have rights and we are
independent and we can do what men can
do these days so there's just like it's
like a
what's the opposite of a retracting
you know if we can do what men can do
well I mean I can pay my own way and I
can put I've been protecting myself in
all my relationships so in that sense
yeah well I'm just thinking if someone
breaks into your apartment who do you
call a man or no I don't you're gonna go
down the side of the bed and and shake
and prepare myself because I'm single I
don't have a man because I had to get
rid of him because he wasn't protecting
me
but
well he wasn't protecting you what do
you mean he wasn't making sure that I'm
safe in all areas mentally
financially oh okay so he didn't make
enough
we didn't make anything I was supporting
him and and happily oh you're dating a
bombs
um yeah I mean I think it's and it's not
wrong I'm not saying that you know that
it's it's wrong that men are like that
because
I can understand it times have changed
we can't deny that it's not men don't go
out and work in Coal Mines anymore and
do you know what I mean so it's
understandable but it's very difficult
for both men and women I feel
what do you what do you think
traditional relationships are they dead
no I don't think they're dead like
everyone has their own take on
traditional relationships I mean what
was he saying about like the woman like
basically staying at home not staying at
home but being the nurturer being like
the emotional and what not one I feel
like yes because men they don't really
show emotion like that
yeah they don't want to because they're
scared getting finessed and whatnot it's
true and like nowadays it's just so hard
to know what's true
yeah it's hard to know it's true like
someone can say they're in love with you
but how did you know they're really in
love with you
you don't think Love's a choice
it's like their actions
you don't think so in some relationships
yes but I think in you know in certain
relationships you don't have a choice
it's like a force you feel forced well I
think that's like long term how it used
to be you know what I mean like because
like you think in a 30 40 year marriage
you're gonna really feel love every day
of course like some years you're
probably not going to like them that
much true what do you think
yeah I agree um so I'll just listen you
know what it was I want to listen to
what you guys had to say before I said
um
sorry okay so yeah so
no I believe traditional relationships
do exist because I still believe they
still happen but if you talk about the
niche
what tradition traditional relationships
and were initially know that that's dead
so you're not really gonna well try
yourself you're getting a woman that's a
virgin right it's it's unlikely
um depending on the age depends on
that's not true
no I'm just saying I'm just saying the
chances in the dating world in the
dating world what percent of women over
the age okay the average age of first
marriage in the UK what what age do you
think it is over 30. it's 31. what
percent of 31 year olds are virgins as
women
probably five girl it is not that high
yeah
31. you're telling me this girl's waited
half her life cat I don't believe a
single girl that tells me she's over
26 I'll give you and it's still a virgin
I don't believe you women are losing
their virginity are like 14 now like
yeah yeah it's because of social media
all these cardi B songs you know
so yeah so sorry yeah so yeah so um so
traditional in a sense of the world yeah
that fundamental what tradition was
based on oh yeah that's gone but there's
there's something else that we could
consider as traditional goals so what's
the one we say if you've got her body
counts over below five or something that
makes her some traditional woman is a
woman with the body count below five no
I'm just saying you can't change you
can't change the definitions
of Virgin 100 but what I mean in a sense
of um
so
like existing and or as part of a
tradition long established that's the
definition of traditional yeah so I
don't think so in order for you to have
a traditional relation traditional man
or your traditional woman so the thing
where a lot of women want to have the
cake and eat it they want to live single
lives while they've got a man and still
want to access some of the benefits of
of being a tradition so for you um Emily
for what you said in regards to the guy
that you you was with he just wasn't a
good guy he was a bum so if you're with
a guy and you're having to pay for him
if he can't offer you any protection
then really and truly what is what what
is the need for him there's no need for
you to have him there but that doesn't
mean that traditional men don't exist in
traditional world don't exist and if you
make money this thing where women now
make money that that was money should
never be a reason that you cannot still
have a man follow his leadership
um and now this thing when where yes you
can go out and earn and you could even
earn more than the man but that does not
mean that his role has diminished now
because a man's role was never just
about money and Finance it shouldn't it
shouldn't but sometimes it does because
of the toxic masculinity and the the
toxic masculinity doesn't exist it
doesn't exist that's the term let's
forget that term then but I'm saying I
agree with you it shouldn't be that way
but unfortunately it is because of
insert whichever word you want
doesn't allow it I think it's it's
hypergamy women want to date across and
up I think it's natural to women but
I don't think money is the end-all
be-all nowadays but has anyone here been
in a traditional relationship that they
would class as traditional or in a
traditional relationship
traditional
um like it to the point
um I guess where the lady like Emily was
saying the lady is the nurturer at home
and the guy is the protective provider
goes out makes the money and the woman's
like a stay-at-home mom I had a taste
of it funnily enough in college I had a
taste
and it
did a job and I was at dance school but
it was that really nice coming home I'm
doing the dinner he's getting in the
bath and you know what I mean so I've
had a taste but with men with over the
age
18 no
oh really why do you think that is
uh my choices first and foremost
um
I wish I knew what happened to the guy
in college yeah why don't you why'd you
keep that one he's the one that got away
kind of because he kissed a girl once in
our early stages and I left him
and I regret it because what I've been
through with my exes after him like he's
a good kiss that's nothing I'm like I
kicked myself I'll be honest with you
how old were you uh this was from 16 to
19. now you're 16. yeah do you ever
think like
women kids yet another girl advise you
to leave
like your friends okay no because I
always I hear a lot of times girls will
leave when they when he cheats but then
they don't find someone they love more
and so it's like you know it's it's like
is it is it better you know
traditional relationship you've been in
one
China
um no because I'll be married then for
me a traditional relationship ends in
marriage okay so if it doesn't matter if
she plays the part for a year or two
years if it doesn't end in actual
marriage then it doesn't matter so it's
like I think sometimes people look back
in relationships and they'll be like oh
yeah oh my ex did this for me or my ex
did that for me but I'll be like if it
didn't end in marriage then what does it
matter what x did for you because they
didn't actually do the ultimate thing
that will show you the traditional man
or woman
um do you believe that relationships
today have to end a marriage yeah for
them to be successful well my thing is
this is is
is
if a man doesn't want to marry you then
he hasn't got good intention for you
long term that's what I believe you
don't think so when men women are paid
to leave the contract it's such a bad
contract nowadays where women are
incentivized to leave so like honestly I
think men have good reason not to want
to get married nowadays no I understand
that but if we if we talk about the
family home and we know about it we know
about all the statistics and and you
know being a two-parent home and having
a father that's in the home like like if
you really care about your family as a
man you would do certain things we also
know that there's certain certain
protections that be marriage does for
your wife as well and does for your
family so I just think ultimately
um if someone loves you that much
they're going to want to make the
ultimate sacrifice and commitment to you
commit with marriage yeah so let me live
with a with a 50 40 divorce rate where
she can leave take half and take your
kids you don't you don't think that some
men want traditional outcomes but
marriage just isn't on the table for
them I I believe marriage is on table
for everybody but it just someone it
depends what you're willing to risk and
a lot these men you had to put risk to
get in the place so to make it easier
though to make it easier right um I want
to like do like a little thought
experiment right so
you have a holiday destination
and it's your best holiday destination
it's the place that you've always wanted
to go and you can get it you can go
there all expenses paid
right
however
when you get on a plane you have a 50
chance of getting to the holiday
destination
are you gonna get on a plane
yeah plain analogies aren't good for me
I don't like planes anyway all right
because it doesn't give you the out
outcome that makes sense to you right
but are you going to get on if it's 50
50 chance to get to that your best
destination that you've always thought
about and you've always cared about and
you've always loved but you've got a 50
50 chance of getting in would you get on
a plane oh okay I'll give another one if
there was uh yeah you haven't answered
that one yeah bro no you know what it is
because you're using a plain analogy and
I just don't really like planes but if
if there's something that I really
wanted that was 50 50 chance that I was
still gonna go and get it and that's the
type of man I am so the risk is worth it
that's disingenuous you know damn no you
would not no because no because I'm not
talking about the plane because you're
talking about uh you're talking about
losing my life money is not losing yeah
because the thing is no but the thing is
with marriage you can marriage marriage
can lead to a lot of men commit a lot of
men are committing suicide after being
you know taken to the cleaners by women
their children being taken their house
being taken their cars being taken and
it's one thing when you're a young guy
but when you're you're 50 55 you're
tired and she can she can leave you and
take all of your money yeah but you have
to understand like
you don't come from that that's not your
what you've seen growing up that's not
what I've seen growing up yes I'm aware
it happens but if that's not what I've
seen growing up then why would I be
scared of it like for me for this thing
that you put this thing is saying I
understand it and another one because
it's a different generation of women
right like we we remember like the women
of that generation were wives yeah but I
I understand that as well but I'm not
going to say all the women are in this
generation are not wives like I think it
makes it quite easy to find the wives
when everyone is clearly not wives right
so if you're if if you meet a woman you
can tell the good women from not the
women that's why they don't they don't
hang around for a lot they get snapped
up so quickly because once you discover
oh my God she's a good one guys are
literally doing the most there's some
girls like like I said before another
show that they don't have to do anything
men just do everything you know why
these aren't the women that are arguing
and beefing you over this over the
stupidest things they literally good
women and and there's not enough of
these women out there so when we spot
them we wipe them and we lock them down
um and these are types of women that get
married not the tattoo but good women
still go Australia I'm going to roll the
dice and this is we can say as women you
know you know ladies ladies we can all
think of one girl that's an absolute
hoar used to be a hoe and she could hide
it but yeah like girls girls are rolled
the dice and I think men think they're a
lot smarter than they are and that's
that's what I'm saying like why like I
you don't think that some guys wouldn't
be interested in marriage because of the
contract incentivizes women to make poor
decisions yeah no I like from a legal
perspective if I was a guy I wouldn't do
it I fully understand what people are
saying I fully understand what you're
saying I'm fully understand what you're
saying but at the same time that's
that's for me that's the union that's
yours yeah I'm not gonna have no baby
mother like that's not something I would
have like I would have a woman that's my
wife like to understand like like to me
okay cool to have a baby mother all it
takes for you to do is have sex with
someone and just and that's it and the
guitar is gonna be the thing is I don't
disagree with you yeah but what I'm
saying is that for me the reason why I'm
asking that is traditional relationships
dead is because we're living in a
different time okay and I think adapting
to the time may be what human beings
need to do and I think sometimes we're
trying to hang on to the old ways and
bring them into the new and we can
clearly see in this Society it's a new
time yeah but it's a really new time
yeah but Sarah in the west I was gonna
say look look as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible